burkini questo capo di abbigliamento su
cui si sono create attorno diverse
discussioni sono stati fatti diversi
interventi in televisione ha scosso
diverse politiche leggi e anche
costituzioni il burkini non è altro che
un capo di abbigliamento per le donne
musulmane per andare al mare e
realizzato il leak il tessuto che si
utilizza per fare i costumi da mare e
idrofobo quindi non assorbe l'acqua e
all'interno dell'acqua non si
appesantisce e non limita i movimenti e
proprio un indumento studiata apposta
per questo io li ho chiamati scandali
scandalosi quelli che sono successi
attorno al burkini perché mi è sembrato
anzi mi sembra tutt'oggi una questione
un po ridicola
sono quelle cose su cui la politica si
appoggia per sviare da quelli che sono i
reali problemi dei paesi pensate che in
francia su 90 interviste in una
settimana ci sono stati oltre 300
interventi e nessuna delle persone che
intervenuta era una donna musulmana con
il velo che portasse il burkini che
potesse dire la sua
erano tutte persone giornalisti
professori studenti persone comuni che
dicono la propria sul burkini venne
chiamata non è stata chiamata nessuna
donna a testimoniare o a dire perché
dovrebbe essere una libertà poterlo
indossare
ovviamente sono stata chiamata anch'io
in diverse trasmissioni
quindi ho messa qualcuna perché io in
italia sono un unico marchio per donne
musulmane made in italy quindi un
marchio che concilia quello che il gusto
italiano con quella che l'esigenza delle
ragazze musulmane che decidono di
portare il velo
trovo ridicolo che nel 2019
stiamo ancora a discutere su che cosa la
donna debba indossare non indossare come
debba debba essere o come
a vestire intanto si parte svantaggiate
nascendo donna perché in questa società
e così la donna è sempre svantaggiata
pensiamo solo a semplici cose come per
esempio la parità nello stipendio ancora
in europa nel mondo non esiste neanche
un paese che ha raggiunto la parità di
stipendio tra uomo e donna la donna
guadagna più o meno 20 per cento meno
dell'uomo quindi in un anno è come se
lavorasse un mese gratis tolta questa
parentesi parti svantaggiata nascendo
donna lasciando donna musulmana e donna
musulmana con il velo perché tu la prima
impressione che dai alle persone e che
sei una donna musulmana con il tuo
aspetto io potevo realtà potevo anche
partire
volevo partire con un'altra introduzione
entrando qui e chiedendovi che cosa
pensate quando mi vedete che cosa
pensate di me e che cosa pensate che io
sia venuto a raccontare o cosa pensate
che io sia venuta a dire perché spesso
quando si vede un musulmano lo si prende
come fosse non so la posizione di un
prete e un musulmano deve parlare solo
di religione e ne deve sapere tutto
invece quando un comune comune altro che
può essere un cristiano un biancone breo
sale su un palco ci si aspetta solo
quello che ha da dire non lo si
classifica già come una figura che fa
parte della religione
diciamo che partì svantaggiata proprio
da sempre
pensate dover convivere con tutte queste
ingiustizie e cerca ancora di spiegare
qualcosa in più ma io mi sono fatta un
attimo una domanda
il problema è che le donne si coprano il
corpo o quali donne si coprono il corpo
qui vedete due versioni di quelle che io
chiamo due versioni di burkini
personalizzate da una parte abbiamo
delle donne cinesi con il face chini in
cina per una questione culturale le
donne si coprono il volto e il corpo per
non diventare scure perché diventando
scure potrebbero essere scambiate per
schiave o contadine invece
dall'altra parte vediamo delle suore che
gioiscono dentro l'acqua che si
divertono e oserei quasi dire che godono
del creato di dio
invece quando nella stessa situazione
una donna musulmana emessa diventa quasi
un insomma un gioco per gli altri io
ricordo che ogni volta che vado al mare
con mia sorella con le mie amiche quando
entriamo in acqua soprattutto perché in
italia sono pochissime le persone che
vanno al mare per nuotare
quando entriamo in acqua a un certo
punto sulla spiaggia si forma proprio
una specie di barriera di tutte le
persone che erano sui lettini sdraiate
uno che chiama l'altro per vedere e si
alzano tutti in piedi a fotografare
delle donne vestite dentro l'acqua o mio
dio
e pensare che anni e anni e anni fa
anche le donne in italia entravano in
acqua vestite poi è arrivato il costume
a manica corta col pantaloncino poi è
arrivata la mutanda ad alta vita con un
top e poi al bikini e poi anche al
topless perché no perché le donne hanno
diritto di vestirsi di svestirsi quando
vogliono finché è una loro libertà
affinché una non c'e una loro scelta ma
noi donne combattiamo lo stesso spesso
un sacco di battaglie le cominciamo in
modo vano sappiamo che andranno perse
però dobbiamo fare la nostra parte e
continueremo a fare la nostra parte
perché una donna che difende la libertà
di un'altra donna difende la sua perché
un giorno tu difendi me perché io possa
indossare il burkini e un giorno io
difenderò te perché tu possa andare in
bikini piuttosto che in topless
piuttosto che con un abito da sera
nessuno ti vieta di andare con un abito
da sera al mare si attendeva
ti va di fare una passeggiata al mare
vestita così e dovrebbe essere una cosa
comune perché le donne in su ma ne sono
donne sono umani come tutte le altre
persone spesso si pensa
chissà se la donna musulmana esce chissà
se parla chissà se lavora chissà come
mangia chissà come si veste come se
fosse un essere particolare viene vista
così praticamente un alieno perché sì
perché quando abbiamo un alieno davanti
non ne conosciamo nulla
e non vogliamo approfondire ma il caso
della donna musulmana è un essere umano
io dire che lo sforzo di approfondire la
personalità e quelle che sono le scelte
dell'altra parte sia abbastanza
importante
oggi sono qui precisamente per parlarmi
di questo essere misterioso la donna
musulmana è una donna intraprendente
ambiziosa creativa passionale
determinata e ordinata in questo caso in
realtà sto parlando proprio di me
vi ricorda qualcosa di più mi piace
mangiare mi piace mettere il piccante il
parmigiano ovunque anche sulla pasta con
le cozze mi piace bere il tè di mio
fratello
mangiare il cous cous di mia madre
mangiare le lasagne di mia cognata tra
l'altro italo palestinese non mi piace
il caffè ma mi piace bere il tè e le
tisane come se fossero acqua mi piace
girare per i negozi guardare le vetrine
rimanera giornata un po su quelle che
sono le tendenze mi piace provare le
ultime hit degli ultimi modelli di
scarpe che sono usciti alle borse e non
mi piacciono tanto i gioielli
mi piace anche ordinare cassetti
utilizzando delle scatole un po alla
mariconda per chi conosce mi piace
ordinare i miei veli per tonalità di
colore in modo che io sia più facilitata
nel momento in cui mi vesto so già se
andare su e giù su quella che l'ordine
dei miei ve li abbiamo un sacco di veli
tantissimi colori tantissime tonalità
stampe texture io personalmente sono una
persona abbastanza minimal quindi tutti
i miei veli sono in tinta unita non
troverete marino stampa ma mi presento
ancora meglio
io sono in la france ho 25 anni
sono nata in marocco a casablanca
sono in italia da oltre 21 anni mi
ritengo italiana se posso permettermi
non ho la cittadinanza italiana per
questioni burocratiche
vi faccio solo un esempio così veloce
mia madre e le sorelle minori hanno la
cittadinanza io no perché sono diventata
maggiorenne
momento della richiesta e quindi sono
stata tagliata fuori gli ultimi due mesi
questo per farvi capire un po anche la
logica della burocrazia quanto per certi
versi e contorta perché per tre anni
consecutivi della richiesta io ne avevo
diritto
appena ho fatto 18 anni pur non ne ho
più diritto quindi o poi richiederla
dovrei avere un certo reddito oppure
dovrei chiedere la per matrimonio dopo
due anni oppure insomma ci sono altre
possibilità che non sono semplici ho
creato una pagina su facebook per
condividere quelle che sono le mie
creazioni con le mie coetanee e ho
cominciato questo perché perché a 13 14
anni ho deciso di indossare il velo
all'insaputa dei miei genitori
facevo una specie di prova di settimana
in settimana e poi un sabato deciso di
metterli dalle non l'ho più tolto l'ho
fatto per amore di dio perché il
concetto del velo è quasi la stessa
identica cosa delle suore verso dio e un
rapporto tra te ed io dove non c'è
nessun intermediare dove non ci deve
essere nessun intermediario perché dio
nel corano o dice chiaramente non c'è
costrizione nella religione quindi una
persona crede per credere in dio non
crede perché lo chiede tuo padre note le
chiede qualcun altro
a differenza di quello che ci si sente
dire attorno o sento di studiare
ragioneria alle superiori perché c'era
più possibilità di lavoro dopodiché ho
deciso di cambiare di tornare a moda
perché non avevo più quello stimolo per
continuare per dare di più anche se devo
dire la verità ma quel percorso mi
piaceva assai ho deciso di spostarmi a
moda ea casa intanto mi portavo un po
avanti cucivo escusivo le cose smontavo
vestiti già pronti per capire come
funzionava un po il meccanismo perché a
scuola era troppo lente il programma io
sono tra l'altro una persona molto
frettolosa e quindi a casa scuci boeri
cucivo smontava rimontava spesso non
riusciva a rimontare le cose purtroppo
ma fa parte dei rischi del mestiere
ricordo che mamma mi ha comprato una
macchina da cucire dull care for a 89
euro in promozione per giocare
con la macchina io ce l'ho ancora oggi è
la utilizzo ancora oggi sono passati
forse più di cinque anni e ogni volta
che la vedo rivivo tutti quei momenti
tutti quei passi che ho fatto nel tempo
creando la pagina su facebook
il mio intento era quello di dire
secondo me il gusto italiano con quella
che la scelta di indossare il velo
questi sono i vestiti che secondo me
possono andare bene che poi
nell'indossare il velo sono pochissime
le regole non devono essere abiti
aderenti trasparenti volgari
principalmente non devono mostrare le
forme ma stiamo parlando di queste
uniche regole per tutto il resto si
spazia per colori per forme per stampe
per tessuti e veramente si possono
creare cose infinite così facendo la
pagina su facebook mi rendo conto che
tutte le mie coetanee ma non lo stesso
problema
pensavo di essere l'unica perché io
avendo la fissa per la moda e per il
disegno dicevo sono l'unica che si fa
tutte queste paranoie mentali invece
erano tutte le ragazze nate e cresciute
in italia musulmane che hanno deciso di
indossare il velo ma che si sentono
italiani che sono italiane e quindi
hanno bisogno di un abito che concili
l'eleganza e la sobrietà italiana con
quella che sono quelle piccole
indicazioni che servono alla ragazza con
il velo del 2015 mi sono diplomata ho
lavorato un anno in un ufficio a cena a
milano con una stilista che si chiama
rossana diana che ringrazio perché
l'esperienza con lei in questo ufficio
mi ha insegnato tantissimo mi ha
insegnato più di quello che ho imparato
a scuola nel 2017 torno a torino perché
facevo la pendio pendolare torino milano
torna a torino e registrò il mio marchio
con il mio nome in modo che sia più
riconoscibile in là frame e diventa
ufficialmente ed effettivamente il primo
ed unico marche per donne musulmane made
in italy
ci tengo a evidenziare made in italy
perché il made in italy è quasi come
dire un certificato di qualità come un
bollo come per dire che qui c'è stato un
controllo che c'è stata una confezione
attenta
purtroppo più andiamo avanti più forse
non è più tanto così sempre per
questioni politiche
taste e quant'altro tutte le aziende più
importanti e più belle del italiane tra
l'altro più famose del mondo stanno
esportando la loro produzione sfilo la
mia prima collezione alla torino fashion
week nel 2017
una collezione composta giorno sera e
sport questa è la collezione da giorno
questo è tutto 100 per 100 lino italiano
forme diverse lunghezze diverse usi
diversi
questa invece è una collezione da sera
in cui faccio una proposta con il
pantalone una con la gonna uno smoking
lungo con dei libri spacconi un completo
composta da tre pezzi e tutto si può
interscambiare alcuni pezzi sono dubbie
fas se proprio una questione un po di
sostenibilità anche perché quello che
più ho imparato durante la mia
esperienza milano ho creato anche la
collezione sportiva
la collezione sportiva va a rafforzare
quello che il mio il mio secondo
obiettivo della linea ovvero creare
connessione interazione integrazione tra
le persone grazie all'abbinamento questo
perché perché vedendo questo abito tu
puoi sfatare quelli che sono i miti che
la donna musulmana non fa sport in onda
cavallo non nuotano fa tennis e
quant'altro e quindi un messaggio
indiretto per far vedere quella che
realmente è la donna musulmana
c'è una tuta da corsa un completo da
equitazione il cosiddetto burkini e una
tuta da tennis che una tuta pantalone
qui forse ma ce ne rendiamo conto
non ho notizia interessante è che di
questo campo di moda chiamato anche mode
station
solo il 18 per cento sono l'undici per
cento anzi è rivolta alle donne
musulmane
tutto il resto è rivolto a donne ebree
cattoliche protestanti e soprattutto
donne che desiderano vestirsi in questo
modo
abito elegante morbido e raffinato un po
come quello che mettono le famiglie
reali lui non vedremo mai una
principessa una reggina con una
scollatura profonda piuttosto che con un
abito con insomma una certa lunghezza ci
sono tante donne che hanno questi gusti
ultima cosa con cui vi voglio lasciare
che ci sono tantissimi brand che si sono
rivolte a donne musulmane ma quasi per
dire credo questo accessorio per
accontentarti per dire ok anch'io ho
fatto qualcosa per voi quella nike ha
creato un velo sportivo ma ne ha creato
uno un solo modello è come dire una
parrucchiera propone un solo taglio per
qualsiasi tipo di volto
io qui porto il turbante che a questo
incrocio se come io il viso rotondo il
turbante melo allunga mia sorella lo
porta in un altro modo perché perché lo
portiamo in base a come ci sentiamo a
nostro agio
io posso solo dirvi
buttatevi del conoscere le altre persone
le altre culture le altre origini pre
sconoscendo cca richiamo a vicenda cioè
io conoscendo un'altra persone posso
conoscere meglio anche me stessa perché
mi viene alla curiosità di approfondire
anche quella che è la mia cultura
qui c'è anche una collezione di dolce
gabbana che però venga solo nei paesi
arabi e oltretutto non è un modello
italianissimo quindi io non lo
indosserei mai un vestito così lungo
così floreale così troppo sgargiante io
vi voglio dire
conoscete buttatevi abbiate diciamo il
coraggio di curiosare io sono una
persona curiosissima io posso sedermi
sul pullman vicino una persona e
mettermi a parlare sedermi in panchina
al giardino e raccontare le storie farmi
raccontare storie dalle signore anziane
perché sono quelle che spesso hanno più
da raccontare vengono meno ascoltate
buttatevi siate coraggiosi e spero che
la mia linea o il concetto della mia
linea possa esservi di aiuto a entrare
di più in quelle che sono le verità
delle persone e non quello che si dice
delle persone l'ultima mia cliente è
stata una donna a cui ho fatto un abito
da sera cui la figlia italiana si è
sposata con un ragazzo
e nella mia linea io italo marocchina
sono riuscita a darle quell'abito che
lei cercava giusto per quell'occasione
che potesse conciliare quello che
l'italiano con quello che l'hard meno
tra l'altro eric amico utilizzato per
dare quel tocco orientale sono ricami di
valentino che mi sono stati regalati
anni fa quindi anche qui sono ricavi di
valentino non sono ricami orientali però
in qualche modo la combinazione richiama
io vi ringrazio tantissimo per
l'attenzione e spero di avervi
incuriosito a curiosare altrove grazie
[Applauso]